hey what's up mkbhd here and i think
sony's finally done it this mountain
they've been climbing for all these
years they've finally reached the top
and they've created the most enthusiast
targeted phone
in the world more than any gaming phone
more than any other niche phone
i recently made a video on why people
don't really buy that many sony phones
they've doubled down on all of that
stuff since then it's kind of a work of
art so i've been using this phone on and
off for about a month now and everything
that you can think of that would make
the ultimate enthusiast phone
they've done it sony's done it in this
phone everything from the specs to the
features to the details it's all here i
mean you can start all the way from the
top with the name it's the xperia one
three
good luck explaining that to your normal
friends and it was unveiled literally
months ago in april so you'd only know
about it now that it's quietly actually
gone on sale because you follow enough
tech blogs or youtube channels because
you certainly won't see any ads for it
or find it in any carrier stores here
but then just look at this design i mean
you can probably already see some of the
enthusiast features starting to stick
out
it's kind of hard to know where to start
actually so first of all it has a super
nice frosted matte black finish and it's
actually even kind of like a little bit
of a soft touch that i really like even
the sides are matte black and the whole
thing is built around this 21x9 aspect
ratio which an enthusiast would love
because now you can watch your 21x9
videos on a proper cinema display with
no black bars but then let's just go
down the feature list okay
dual sim card tray at the top removable
without a tool and the second sim card
tray actually doubles as expandable
storage for those micro sd cards up to a
terabyte your welcome enthusiasts
there's stereo front-facing speakers
flanking the edges of the phone and
they're nice and loud louder than the
previous generation and far enough apart
to create a nice real stereo image and
then up in the corner
yeah that's an led notification light
the feature you really don't see in many
features nowadays but that enthusiasts
will appreciate
and as i say that you're probably
already thinking about a headphone jack
so yeah the headphone jack is up here
too up top feels like the phone is
barely thick enough for it and this one
actually also has some extra buttons so
there's a volume rocker up top then the
super reliable fingerprint reader power
button combo underneath that then a
custom button that's mapped to trigger
google assistant
then underneath that a dedicated shutter
button for the camera system and it's
got the half press for focusing and the
full press for actually taking the shot
and everything all of that wrapped in a
body that's ip68 water resistant and
pretty squared off overall
maybe a little bit of a boring design to
some but
i like it i really like it it's the
finish it's the overall like pretty
square aesthetic that i've liked in the
past but it's just it's nice the
fingerprint reader on the power button
is very fast and very reliable so i'm a
fan of that and just the whole phone is
of course very easy and comfortable to
hold because it's so narrow because
21x9
but speaking of 21x9
let's talk about the screen this phone
has a six and a half inch 4k
120 hertz display right off the bat
jesus in in the settings you can switch
between the super smooth 120 hertz or
just normal 60 hertz but you actually
cannot adjust the screen resolution at
all it is always locked at 4k which is a
little bit crazy i mean i get that it's
an enthusiast phone and only an
enthusiast would want to toggle their
phone to 4k sometimes to you know watch
a 4k youtube video or a movie or
something but
this is just 4k all the time this is
full-on maximum enthusiast if you
literally can't turn it off no 1080 no
1440 it's locked i'm actually kind of
surprised they do let you turn off 120
hertz i don't know maybe they'll remove
that option in the mark iv
the display itself though it looks
pretty great as you might expect sony
has this 10-bit creator mode it's had it
before and it's also a highly adjustable
white balance to tune this oled display
to look exactly how you'd want i'd
expect nothing less here but of course
the downside to having a 21x9 display is
there are still some apps that aren't
perfectly optimized for it and honestly
probably never will be that includes
instagram stories and tick tock you know
the normie apps most everyday people use
they have black bars at the top and the
bottom because most phones aren't this
crazy tall aspect ratio but that's fine
this is an enthusiast phone and so
people who are willing to make that
sacrifice to have a nice narrow taller
better looking display with cinema
videos
they'll be fine with that couple apps
not working no big deal this is gonna be
great with 21 by nine stuff the one
thing you can't get around though is
having a display at 4k 120 hertz all the
time
yeah it eats into battery life pretty
hard so this phone has a 4500 milliamp
hour battery which is solid but that's
not gigantic but the rate that you can
chew through battery at high brightness
4k 120 hertz is pretty high so i'd
recommend you have one of those
enthusiast battery banks somewhere near
you if you plan on getting a whole day
past about four hours a heavy screen on
time away from your charger the brick
included does get you 30 watt fast
charging and it does have qi wireless
charging as well but yeah if there is a
weak point of this hyper-enthusiast
phone it's definitely that so you've got
your crazy enthusiast hardware with the
headphone jack and the notification led
you've got your crazy enthusiast screen
4k
uh you've got your enthusiast specs of
course you got snapdragon 8 12 gigs of
ram and the works are all here but
what's it like to actually use this
phone with such crazy hardware
you guessed it it's riddled with quirks
and features i'd feel like doug demiro
trying to point all of these out there's
a lot going on now sony software
actually think overall is pretty nice
mostly because let's be real they don't
try to do too much aesthetically it's
like if you took near stock android 11
and then just plugged a bunch of
features into it that work with sony's
hardware i mean that's what an
enthusiast like me wants so you've got
your near stock looking quick settings
and the google discover feed next to
your home screens even the default
google search box at the very bottom of
your home screen for reachability but
then in the settings like i've said you
have a ton of display customization you
have always on display controls reverse
wireless charging toggle lots of battery
care features to help you reduce the
amount of time your battery spends at
full 100 charge to prolong the life of
your phone and then one of my favorite
sony editions is called side sense so
sony fans taught me if you've heard this
before but it puts this little bar over
here to the side of your screen you can
double tap that bar anytime you want to
bring up a quick app launcher which you
can customize with whatever eight apps
you want or just bring up the whole list
hilariously
and then you can slide up on that bar
anytime you want to open multitasking
which is pretty sweet on that extra tall
21 by 9 display i assume if you're a
true enthusiast you're doing this all
the time and you've got your favorite
app pairs queued up so you can launch
them both at the same time with a single
touch
and you can also launch one-handed mode
from here which makes sense if you can't
quite reach the top of this phone
honestly it's so tall that the top
corners can be a little annoying to
reach even with big hands so you can
customize the position of this bar the
size the transparency level the
sensitivity every little thing dial it
to your heart's content and it's all
over here in this little sidebar that's
super reachable wherever you want to put
it well done sony this one has really
good strong haptics which is good to see
always and there's also dualshock 4
support so you can connect a sony ps4
controller to this phone to play certain
games if you're into that i imagine
they're building in
a dual sense 5 support it doesn't work
with the ps5 controller yet but that
would be cool but you want to know you
want to know the worst part of the
software though
for some reason
and this annoyed me a lot
this phone has the slowest auto rotate
i've ever witnessed
in a modern smartphone
yeah that's not a bug it's
it's that slow
every single time i don't know why i
feel like this is either a
i guess it is a bug and they can fix it
with software
but yeah that's that was extremely
annoying now an enthusiast phone
wouldn't be complete without some
enthusiast cameras and boy does sony
have that on lock here
literally there is no basic android
camera app as soon as you squeeze that
shutter or double tap the power button
or just hit the camera icon whatever you
like you're thrown immediately into
sony's advanced camera app now they do
give you a basic mode in that camera app
which is funny and that lets you switch
to video mode and toggle between the
ultra wide the standard and two
different telephoto focal lengths but
then of course you can just go straight
from basic mode into basically a full on
sony alpha camera with programmable auto
modes and manual modes and 20 fps burst
shutter and slider sphere shutter speed
and iso and focus and all that it's
great but did you catch one little thing
i just said there two telephoto focal
lengths
but there's only one
telephoto camera on the back of the
phone so how are there two telephoto
focal lengths well it turns out quietly
for their hyper-enthusiast phone sony's
dropped
variable
optical zoom
on a single telephoto camera so this
horizontally oriented telephoto camera
has glass inside that moves to change
the focal length optically instead of
digitally so in the software you can
snap these between 70 millimeters and
105 millimeters these focal lengths are
both shot by that same sensor it's
pretty intense now sony won't tell me
exactly how they're doing this i guess
it's a secret but i imagine there are
probably some sort of magnets involved
moving the glass around the best i can
show is this animation on sony's youtube
channel one of their videos but this
animation actually shows several
different internal lens positions which
kind of confused me because there's only
two focal lengths so i don't know what
this is about or how accurate this
visualization is but you get the idea
it's moving glass inside the phone to
give you two different zooms and so the
result is kind of amazing you now have
two different
focal lengths of telephoto in one sensor
you have 70 and you have 105 and you can
digital zoom between them but you can
also just snap between them back and
forth for optical zoom to match
sharpness that's pretty cool the brutal
part though is even after all that
technical wizardry
the photo quality really isn't that
great like i'd like to think i know what
i'm doing and i've shot with plenty of
cameras plenty of sony alpha cameras and
other sony phones but it's just never
actually looked
that great despite all the incredible
innovative manual control the shutter is
very fast autofocus is incredibly fast i
never miss a shot with the dedicated
shutter button it's awesome
but the actual shot i get
pretty soft a little bit muted colors a
little noisy sometimes
pretty meh so i was hoping for better
there so the best thing i get out of
this phone's camera system really is
just it's a technical marvel and it's
really cool to appreciate
and i have hope for the future of
smartphones with optical zoom but i also
don't want to get my hopes up because
well if you remember what samsung did
with dual aperture in the galaxy s9
it was kind of just like this it wasn't
smoothly adjusting aperture between a
range but you could snap between two
different apertures on the same camera
lens with a moving lens that was in the
samsung galaxy s9
and then the next year it was gone and
it never showed up again
and it would have been really useful in
some of their later years galaxy s20
having such a thin plane of focus having
dual aperture could make a bigger range
of focus if you shut down the aperture a
little bit but they didn't do it anymore
so i see that and then i think of sony's
where now you're snapping between focal
lengths and it's cool and i hope it
advances but there's no guarantees so
we'll cross our fingers for that but
overall sheesh this this phone
is a lot it's got a camera i've never
seen before it's got a screen i've never
seen before it's got a ton of features
there's just a lot going on and so if
you care about smartphones at all this
is a really exciting phone and aside
from the awful auto rotate i thoroughly
enjoyed using it now would i recommend
it
honestly probably almost no one should
actually buy this phone i mean it is
1200 bucks that's how much i get it for
it's on b h right now i
you can get a galaxy s21 ultra for that
price which would have better battery
faster charging better cameras better
software with more updates and just
overall a bit more versatile so you have
to you have to really want
this but if you are that enthusiast or
if you're into
sony headphones or sony ps5 or sony
i don't know bravia tvs or the other
stuff they make then
you might consider this one too
so there you have it that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
you